in this segment we will first discuss
and compare different views of the sum
of independent identically distributed
random variables and then we will
conclude with the statement of the
central limit theorem so let x1 up to xn
be independent identically distributed
random variables that have a certain
finite mean and finite variance that we
denote by mu and Sigma squared in order
to have a concrete example in our hands
let us assume that this random variable
has a distribution let's say a PDF that
ranges from minus 1 to plus 1 and has a
mean of 0 let us look at the sum of
these random variables the sum has a
variance of n times Sigma squared which
goes to infinity and correspondingly
the standard deviation of this random
variable also grows to infinity this
random variable takes values between
minus N and plus N and because the
variance and the standard deviation
increase this means that for larger and
larger n the width of this distribution
is going to be larger and larger we can
obtain a different view of this sum if
we divided by n in which case we obtain
the sample mean in this case the
variance goes to 0 as n goes to infinity
and as a consequence the distribution is
highly concentrated around 0 this is
also what the weak law of large numbers
tells us the bulk of the distribution is
concentrated in an arbitrarily small
interval around 0 so this width becomes
smaller and smaller as n goes to
infinity so in this case we obtain a
limiting distribution but this limiting
distribution is trivial it's degenerate
it's all concentrated on a single point
how can we make it so that we obtain a
limiting distribution that is more
interesting the key is to divide not by
n
but to divide by the square root of n
this has the following effect the
variance of this ratio is calculated as
follows we take the variance of the
numerator which is n times Sigma squared
and then we divide by the square of this
number which is N and therefore the
variance is equal to Sigma squared
what's important here is that the
variance stays constant no matter what n
is the width of this distribution is
going to be more or less the same the
distribution itself might change as n
changes but the distribution in list in
this case where we assumed zero mean the
distribution stays in place it doesn't
move to the right or to the left and its
width stays the same so one can wonder
in the limit as n goes to infinity does
this shape start to approach a certain
limiting shape and if it does what is
the limiting shape that it approaches
the central limit theorem will give us
the answers to these questions the
setting for the central limit theorem
will be pretty much the setting that we
were just discussing so we will be
looking into the case where we divide
the sum of the random variables by
square root of n except for a few
additional twists since this ratio has a
variance of Sigma squared it would help
to divide by a further factor of Sigma
here so that the variance is going to
become 1 and there's another issue if
the mean of the XS is nonzero then the
distribution is centered at the quantity
that keeps changing with n so the
distribution will be drifting away from
0 it's not staying in place and so it
wouldn't have any hope of converging to
something for this reason instead of
looking at this ratio in particular what
we do is
we first subtract the mean of the sum
which is n times the mean and then we
divide by a further factor of Sigma this
random variable that we obtained here
has nice properties the mean of this
random variable is equal to 0 because we
did subtract the mean of the axes and
the variance of this random variable is
going to be equal to 1 the reason is
that the variance is the variance of the
numerator which is n times Sigma squared
divided by the square of the denominator
which is also n times Sigma squared so
as n changes the distribution of the
random variable Z n stays in place it
has a mean of 0 and its width more or
less stays the same because we have a
constant variance we will compare this
random variable with a standard normal
random variable that has 0 mean and unit
variance the central limit theorem
states the amazing fact that as n goes
to infinity the distribution of this
random variable converges to the
standard normal distribution in the
following sense that this probability
here converges to that probability for
any choice of little Z now what we have
here is just the CDF of this random
variable Z n so it tells us that the CDF
of the random variable Z n converges to
the CDF of a standard normal and
fortunately for the standard normal the
CDF is available in tables so if we need
to calculate the numerical value here we
can just look up the normal tables and
this suggests an approximation to this
probability for the case where n is
finite but large when n is large we can
approximate this probability by this
probable
on the right which we can find from the
normal tables the central limit theorem
is a very important result for this
reason we will spend some time
discussing how to interpret it what it
means how we use it and we will go
through a few examples to see how we
actually apply it